une minute de silence en hommage à
mirelle à morrow a ouvert le conseil
citoyen spéciale sécurité de volga plage
hier soir puis les larmes et les mots de
l'une des filles de la victime de la
fusillade du mardi 21 mai des mots qui
ont touché l'assistance formé de
citoyens de volga est d'ailleurs
d'associations de syndicats d'élus et de
représentants de l'état
la réunion commence par un constat connu
la circulation d'armes
l'augmentation de la pauvreté du trafic
de drogue puis les prises de paroles
s'enchaînent reprenons le contrôle de
nos quartiers les grands frères
soyez des grands frères lorsque j'étais
plus jeune je marchais à minuit 1h du
matin dans le quartier parce que je
savais que mon frère avait des amis qui
étaient les grands frères et vivent au
plaisir mais qu'est ce que tu fais là
cette hiérarchie 3 à l'issue de la
réunion les citoyens sont sceptiques
c'était une grande messe de plus parce
que la jeunesse vraiment concerné des
balles mais puisqu'ils ont été évoqués
ne nous paraissent pas les solutions
réellement puisque notre vie ça a déjà
même été laissés n'avons pas eu de
réconfort pour nous dire que devons nous
faire comme devons nous attendre de nous
mêmes quelle est la sécurité est ce que
nous aurons des ondes de la police je
veux pas fataliste mais là je ne crois
pas qu'ils sont comment faire il va
falloir trouver du côté des services de
l'état on affirme qu'il y a deux
réponses
l'une sécuritaire avec une enquête en
cours pour retrouver les malfaiteurs
une autre social économique avec des
actions à mener auprès des familles en
difficulté
autre volet important l'éducation je
vais pouvoir prochainement monsieur le
recteur justement pourquoi on se
penchera sur ses élèves en décrochage en
difficulté dès le plus jeune âge
ida qui tiennent plus sur les bancs
d'une école pour les insérer en tout cas
à leur proposer les solutions
d'apprentissage aucune solution miracle
n'a été trouvé mais les participants
sont d'accord sur un point
l'action doit être collective massive et
à long terme pour éradiquer la violence